[Music]
even from space you can see that the
planet Earth is full of life when you
take a closer look you'll discover a
delicate balance of millions of
different life-forms coexisting and
relying on each other to survive but
what if these aren't all unique
individual organisms what if they're all
just extensions of one super organism
the earth could we all just be part of
our planets life-support system what
scientific proof is there to support
this idea this is what if and here's
what would happen if earth was one
living organism think of the earth as
being like a human body when our body
starts to overheat it has its own
perspiration system to help regulate its
temperature and cool down when Earth
starts to overheat it has its own system
of plant and animal life to regulate its
atmosphere and control the temperature
but now our planet is heating up at a
pace that is beyond its abilities to
keep fixing itself and that's due to us
which begs the question are we part of
Earth's regulatory system or are we a
disease that has come to disrupt it
today we're gonna do things a little
differently instead of our usual
approach of looking at what would happen
if the earth became one living organism
we're gonna focus on the theory that it
might have been one all along the main
theory that puts this idea forward is
called the Gaia theory named after the
Greek goddess of Earth this theory
argues that all living organisms along
with their inorganic surroundings
adapted and evolved as a collective
whole in the form of one giant
self-regulating system that keeps checks
and balances in place in order for life
to survive on earth
we know this sounds like the kind of
theory that might have come from the
smokey tents of a hippie commune but it
actually came from a highly accredited
scientist named James Lovelock he came
up with this theory while studying the
question of why Earth's atmosphere is
different from what we see on Mars why
does our planet have both oxygen and
methane when Mars has mainly carbon
dioxide his thinking is that since
oxygen comes from plants and methane is
the result of bacteria the earth is
regulating its atmosphere providing
oxygen to support life and methane to
help maintain a livable temperature over
the years he found more instances of the
earth basically keeping itself alive and
his theory started to attract prominent
supporters such as former US Vice
President Al Gore but despite all the
people who supported the Gaia theory
there were far more critics who
dismissed it one such critic is an
evolutionary biologist named dr. Ford
Doolittle yep dr. Doolittle he argues
that the entire theory violates the
scientific method since it only provides
ideas but offers no real explanation of
exactly how organisms could act together
to maintain a balance of life on earth
as it stands now this is a matter that's
still up for debate but the opponents of
the Gaia theory probably hold the edge
if nothing else the Gaia theory can at
least be beneficial to our society as an
ideal to encourage people to take better
care of our planet if we look at
ourselves as being a part of our
planet's regulatory system then we might
choose to make more conscious decisions
to aid that system rather than to
destroy it maybe one day we'll look back
at the Gaia theory as the beginning of a
better understanding of our role on
earth but that's a topic for another
what-if
[Music]